je veux pas parler chez célestine
maman c'est le style
et voilà chez nous
vous allez fermer la porte à clé je
pourrais même échappé pour s'échapper
faut être enfermé ici tu l'est pas vous
avez le droit d'arrêter des gens tout le
garde-chasse jean nord de la forêt et
des voleurs d'enfants oui enfin
braconniers totoche car deux touchés
borel qui pour moi pour me dire et nous
je n'ai jamais jurer tu sais pas ça
voilà deux petites wallonne le pôle
gestion
[Musique]
je te fais chevalier dans l'ordre d'une
pêche à la mouche
c'est sabra connais bien qui fuyait un
jour sur un domaine formation à l'autre
qui est ce jeune garçon que je suis
entraîné le parisien que j'ai pour les
vacances mais ni les anges après
monsieur le comte muller états généraux
s'il a récemment tiré parfois juste que
son auteur
personne ne l'a jamais vraiment ch
sacré seniors
[Musique]
parti vers l'année
je pu voir traîner en forêt sinon je le
remets dans le premier train pour paris
ses terres alors tu vois plus tu lui
parles a plu
ma mère tu le connaissais non c'est pas
comme ça au cjd ward takkal base la vie
révèle enfin quand elle veut bien vous
avez plus de temps
bon alors on et paris bon ça empêche pas
de pousser à teymuraz
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]